what are the things that will completely
change astronomy over the next hundred
years like if you transport yourself
forward 100 years what are the things
that will blow your mind when you look
at wait what
would it be just a very high resolution
mapping of things like holy crap like
one surprising thing might be holy crap
there's
like Earth-like moons everywhere yeah
another one could be just totally
different devices for sensing
yeah I think you usually astronomy moves
forward dramatically and Science in
general when you have a new
technological capability to come online
for the first time
um and we kind of just give examples of
that there with the solar system so what
kind of new capabilities might emerge in
the next 100 years the capability I
would love to see is not just I mean we
in the next 10 20 years we're hoping to
take these pale blue dot images we spoke
about so that requires building
something like jwst but on even larger
scale and optimize for direct Imaging
would have to be the corona graph or a
star shade or something to block out the
Starlight and reveal those pale blue
dots so in the next sort of decades I
think that's the achievement that we can
look forward to in our lifetimes is to
see photos of other Earths going beyond
that maybe in our lifetimes towards the
end of our lifetimes perhaps I'd love it
if we I think it's technically possible
as breakthrough stars are giving us a
lot of encouragement with to maybe send
a small probe to the nearest stars and
start actually taking high resolution
images of these objects there's only so
much you can do from far away
if you want to have and we can see it in
the solar system I mean there's only so
much you can learn about Europa by
pointing Hubble Space Telescope at it
but if you really want to understand
that that Moon you're going to have to
send something to orbit it to hopefully
land on it and drill down to the surface
and so the idea of even taking a flyby
and doing a snapshot photo that gets
beamed back that could be doesn't even
have to be more than 100 pixels by 100
pixels that even that would be a
completely game-changing capability to
be able to truly image these objects and
um maybe at home in our own solar system
we can certainly get to a point where we
produce crude maps of exoplanets
um one of the kind of the ultimate limit
of what a telescope could do is governed
by its size and so the largest telescope
you could probably ever build would be
one that was the size of the sun
there's a clever trick for doing this
without physically building a telescope
that's the size of the sun and that's to
use the Sun as a gravitational lens this
was proposed I think by vaneshleman in
like 1979 but it builds upon Einstein's
theory of General activity of course
that there is a warping of light a
bending of light from the sun's
gravitational field and so a distant
Starlight it's like a magnifying glass
anything that bends light is is
basically can be used as a telescope
it's going to bend light to a point now
it turns out the Sun's gravity is not
strong enough to create a you know a
particularly great telescope here
because the focus point is really out in
the Kuiper belt it's at 550 astronomical
units away from the earth so 550 times
further away from the Sun than we are
and we've you know that's beyond any of
our spacecraft we've ever gone so you
have to send a spacecraft to that
distance which would take
30 40 years even optimistically
improving our chemical propulsion system
significantly you'd have to bound into
that orbit but then you could use the
entire Sun as your telescope and with
that kind of capability you could image
planets to kilometer scale or resolution
from afar and that that really makes you
wonder I mean if we can conceive maybe
we can't engineer it but if we can
conceive of such a device
what might other civilizations be
currently observing about our own planet
um and
perhaps that is uh why nobody is is
visiting us because there is so much you
can do from afar that to them that's
enough they you know maybe they can get
to the point where they can set our
radio leakage and they can trip that
restaurant in you know television
signals
um they can map out our surfaces they
can tell we have cities they can even do
infrared mapping of the heat island
effects and all this kind of stuff they
can tell the chemical composition of our
planet and so that might be enough maybe
they don't need to come down to the
surface and study atopla you know do
anthropology and see what a civilization
is like
um but there's certainly a huge amount
you can do which is significantly
cheaper to some degree than flying there
just by exploiting cleverly the physics
of the universe itself
so your intuition is this very well may
be true the observation might be way
easier than travel
from uh from our perspective from an
alien perspective like we could get very
high resolution
Imaging before we can ever get there it
depends on what what information you
want if you want um to know the chemical
composition
um and and you want to know kilometer
scale maps of the planet then you could
do that from afar with some uh version
of these kind of gravitational lenses if
you want to do better than that if you
want to image a newspaper sat on the
porch of somebody's house you're gonna
have to fly there there's no way unless
you had you know a task at the size of
such serious a star or something you
just simply cannot collect enough light
to do that from many light years away so
there is certainly uh
reasons why visiting will always have
its place depending what kind of
information you want